sister chen was our campaign secretary
wherever you are
if you can come here on
the stage
you're here okay this sister jane was
our campaign secretary
and our role is very simple it's gonna
call all the candidates
the candidates when you hear your name
please come here
in front i will give you your
certificate
you will stand behind me then after we
have called all the names
we'll call all the pastors and elders
who are blessing to
give you a hand of welcome to god his
family
amen amen
so sister jane if you can come up here
uh somebody to help us with the marks
here in the front
good afternoon children of god
and the first name i'm going to read is
of
ruth arena
amen amen
welcome ruth
followed by miriam mossetti
thank you miriam maseri
miriam wasseri is pastor's wife and i'm
so glad
that she made her commitment to jesus
today
welcome miriam
adria momani
[Applause]
sarah
tamo
sarah if the parent is here you can come
okay let's go to another one faith in
yabuto
fight
they see more salty
okay go ahead
nancy nyagaka
[Applause]
thank you nancy god bless you you can
tell
yandusi
[Music]
foreign thank you tiffany god bless you
sandra thank you janelle yeah
sonia kundi thank you sandra god bless
you
abigail mercedes thank you sonia
god bless you
amanda charles
[Applause]
samuel yagaka
thank you mario that god bless you may
reach
hungary
samuel god bless you
andrew and jinger
you can spread john monnari proud of
yourself
thank you frank
katherine mogire
andrew thank you god bless you
edwin mugee thank you john
god bless you
[Music]
to worry
catherine thank you god bless you
thank you cadilla victor
god bless you
[Music]
thank you victor god bless you
okay uh this
are all our candidates that were
baptized today what do you say to god
amen a big amen for god
and the word he has done and i present
them to the judge family
i call upon pastor randy here you can
come and pasta makua
and give a hand of welcome all my
pastors who are here
my church elders please come on here
and give a hand of welcome to these
newly baptized
members of god's family
[Music]
yeah just knock just knock them
amen amen amen
welcome to goddess family we are so
excited that you are here
basta maranga homeless
give them a hand of welcome judge elders
who are here
you are a charge elder
[Music]
so
pastor you are going to pray for them
and i will let them sit down
[Music]
just before i pray when peter preached
the sermon
on the day of pentecost in acts chapter
the people said in verse 37 now when
they heard this they were pricked in
their heart
and said unto peter and the rest of the
apostles
men and brethren what shall we do and
peter said unto them repent
and be baptized every one of you in the
name of jesus christ for the remission
of sins
and ye shall receive
the gift of the holy ghost and so we
want to keep
ask god to keep his word and so we will
pray
and ask god to give those who were
recently baptized
a special measure of his holy spirit
as he promised in acts 2 38.
we also know in acts 5 32 that god gives
the spirit to those who obey him
and they have done this so now i'll ask
all of them who are physically able to
kneel
and i will pray for you let's kneel and
pray
our father in heaven we thank you for
the working of your holy spirit
we thank you thank god for the powerful
conviction of your word
and for the decisions that were made by
those kneeling in your holy presence
and those online who also made decisions
in other countries
father your word states in acts 2 38
repent and be baptized
every one of you in the name of jesus
christ
for the remission of sins and ye shall
receive the gift of the holy ghost
in the name of jesus christ there god
who cannot lie neither can you lie
father
grant these sons and daughters of yours
a special measure of your spirit right
now
that they may be sustained their god and
strengthened
and renew that outpouring day by day as
they walk in the steps of jesus
bless them their god sustain them i pray
and let their lives inspire others to
make a similar decision
bless their families and father when you
come
save every one of them i pray in jesus
name
amen god bless you my brothers and
sisters
you can go and see it and place those
certificates here you can give them to
your church class
whatever church you go to so they can
get you to the
uh the church ledger store charge book
whatever we call it
god bless each one of you
god bless you pastor for the prayer
[Music]
as you know or as we may know today
there were three
separate campaigns that were conducted
during these three weeks
we had the children our department
running their own campaign
we had also the youths the youth
learning also the evangelistic campaign
uh i wish i could
have given the readers a minute to give
us a report
but i realized that we don't have much
time
but let me save those readers julian
and kevin wherever you are in the kitty
may god bless you for the work that you
did
i logged into your programs a couple of
times
and it was a blessing and our children
and
young people were blessed by those
our programs
members of our both judges
our faith international and the lmc i
want to say a big
thank you to all of you for your players
and for your support in this
evangelistic campaign
you gave and that is why we were able to
run this campaign
and more particularly i want to thank
that member
who was touched with a message
and they gave us a check of six thousand
dollars and forty to watch this
evangelistic campaign what do you say
amen that remember who gave us that much
for this campaign we want to say may god
bless you
in this world and the world to come
elder camera a david if you can stand
and
wave edo camera was my first german
and they did a great job okay thank you
for your coordination may god bless you
if you can wave thank you so much
may god bless you for your work well
done
our sister jane shem was our secretary
sister jane we are so much thankful for
the work well done
may god give a double portion of his
blessings and your families
as we wait for his own return to take us
home
the entire organizing committee team
wherever you are can you stand up the
entire organizing theme
wherever you are please stand up that is
the organizing theme may god
bless you abundantly sincerely
uh this coveted 19 gave us a lot of
challenges
and i want to thank each one of you for
your ideas
for your support for the technical part
that you prayed
i'm so very much thankful and may god
bless all of you
music department our brother frank
wherever you are and your team
we have been blessed by the franks back
there and your team
all the solos you did the music
may god bless you the ammo and sisters
may god bless you
all those who participated in blessing
this
campaign may god bless you
i mean let me forget to mention your
name from here in the pulpit
but i'm sure that your name will not be
forgotten
in the heavenly courts may god bless you
in appointment our music department
our team the dictionary department
may god bless you uh airsalon wherever
you are may god bless you
george who has been running up and down
me god bless you
are you and the able the young men who
were
behind there to help us with taking
temperature
may god bless you abundantly
in this world and even the world to come
the communication department
braden yamawa thank you very much can
you stand up brother yamawa
just away under your team
george and renz almond
lens all the communication team
thank you very much you started from
nowhere
but today you are somewhere in
broadcasting god is
what the entire world what do you say
church amen
even our viewers from home you know
from wherever you are viewing the
program
you can confess that this team has
really tried and therefore may god
bless you bless you and bless you
i don't also want to forget dickson and
isaiah and amanda were part of the team
may god bless you all our prayer
committee
headed by sarah ecker i don't know if
sister sarah is here
but wherever you are may god bless you
sis back there
may god bless you this team will have
been praying for all over two months and
they have done a tremendous job may god
bless you and your team
uh i can't remember them all but they
were about 12 in number
who have been praying for this
evangelist campaign may god bless you
the pastor of families the makwas the
okemos the marangas thank you very much
when we needed help you came in and they
gave us the help we needed
may god bless you abundantly
my elders my pastor school came here to
give the announcements
and the and any updates that we had
pastor mccoy
lancer the david and myself pastor
callings
wherever you are may god bless you for
the work you did
may god bless you bless you and bless
you
our guests i don't know if uh brother
ekka is here his brother ekka is here
uh pastor ecker
i don't see pastor hakka is brother naja
here
dr ninja
you can stand and the way
he was handling finance i hope you are
all blessed amen
and then is not here the one who was in
charge of hell
no i is not here but wherever they are i
want to say may god bless them
for the messages that they brought to us
family life was wonderful
health was wonderful our finance speaker
was wonderful and
we say glory and the honor to be
to god
the makaya family is jealousy here
charles is there the mokaya family we
are so much
thankful for hosting our guests
and you have had our guest conversing
from here that he has been living in a
very
good place we thank you adam mokaya for
hosting our guests
may god bless you and your family too
our online viewers you give us the
energy
and enthusiasm because
when we got the reports that there are
over two thousand three thousand five
thousand
viewers you gave us the energy to keep
on you know procasting this message
our online viewers wherever you are may
god bless you
may the actual word that has been spoken
bring a total transformation to your
life
as we wait for the soon return of our
lord to take us home
may god bless you and our church members
of course many of you who are viewing
the program
from home may god bless you and bless
you
abundantly our guest pastor randy
wherever you are may god bless you
for the spoken word
i think all of you as you all sitted
before me today
you can give a testimony that you were
challenged
during these three weeks right
you were challenged even myself i was
challenged
with the act forward of god which was
spoken
by servants i saw the word real
as it was in the time of creation when
god said
let there be right and there was what
there was right
the word was very powerful the what
uh throughout these three weeks came in
a very strong way
and i want to thank god for pastor rand
skate
and i want to pray for him his ministry
and whatever is preaching may he
continue to be used by
god as a vessel to communicate
these messages to the world as we wait
for the soon return
of our lord and savior jesus christ to
take us home
pastor mccoy thank you you gave us the
opportunity
amidst the fears of covet 19 and the
challenges you gave us the opportunity
you gave us the hope
they opt simulate let's go ahead we
don't need to cancel this
and the hand of god has seen as true
thank you pastor
thank you for your leadership may god
bless you and your family how many would
you say god bless our pastor and his
family
all those hands say god bless you pastor
now i think i've done if i have
forgotten
anyone because i'm a human being as well
if any of you participated and i did not
mention your name i want to say a big
thank you for your participation
and may god bless you we will hear from
our district pastor pastor makua
and pastor will invite pastor randy and
after pastor randy
then that would be the cry max of our
evangelistic
series may god bless you and have a
wonderful time
as we wait for the blessed hope of the
time of our lord jesus christ pastor
mccoy
thank you
so
amen thank you very much
mr fred for the opportunity that you've
given to me
i'm standing before you tonight
[Music]
i stand before you with a lot of
humility
at the same time i say to god be the
glory
for the great things he has done
honestly speaking let me say this
when you decide to do something for god
do it
[Music]
nothing should limit you including money
even the preacher in his salmon he said
god will provide
[Music]
sometimes we vent a lot we cry a lot
because of the financial limitations but
i can say
i have seen god's hands
in this evangelistic
series we had a big budget
and there are some who said
we will not give but i say that's okay
and there's some who said they will give
and i saw and i saw
people giving in big number
and including just two three days ago
when one of us is it i've been touched
and i'm giving to my best
and pastors said the number over six
thousand imagine
some people are just saying let me see
how it will go
and some said i'm not going to give
again i say when it comes to god's
business don't allow
financial obligation to be a limitation
[Music]
if you have the desire if you have the
will
do it god will provide you say i'm doing
this
for you then god can you provide
and he will provide out of this
evangelistic
campaign we have a testimony
even kobe 19 said how can we do
these meetings during this season
there was those communications that we
cannot do anything people will come to
church
and they will get the virus and the
church will be closed
[Music]
and we can also be sued i said we serve
a living god
who will protect
[Music]
and for sure you will agree with me
not even one person
fell sick leave alone covey 19 any
sickness
[Music]
and also we were asking where
are the numbers for people to be
baptized nowadays there is that
tradition where people
prepare others for baptism way before
and they just come and do the
the the evangelism meetings and then the
baptized
when we started we didn't have we said
our work even i told pastor randy
our work is to lift up jesus christ and
he will draw
all men and women to himself and we you
can see
god has provided it is his business
our work is to lift him up therefore
brothers and sisters
i feel so humbled when i'm standing in
your presence as pastor fred has said
i have seen how we have worked well as
your district pastor
two churches coming together working
together
harmoniously pastor
fred being the personal ministry
director of
ramsey fred o'keemua
and david o'keemua pastor of ministries
director of faith church
working together very closely
with the teams i attended those meetings
we were talking together we were talking
together brothers and sisters in christ
when there's an issue
we sit down and they talk and
not conflict no disagreement
you know and that's why i can i can see
that the devil doesn't like
people working together he doesn't like
unity he loves bringing
chaos love bringing
this unity so that god's work may not go
on so i
really want to say thank you
very much to the team led by pastor okay
and all other ministries all other alias
you have mentioned it but allow me to
say thank you very much the
communication department i'm really
proud of you
i'm really proud of you
you are here before time and you know
sometimes
when you're at home you don't know what
goes beyond
the scene behind you don't know what's
going on you can enjoy the the streaming
it looks nice
but these gentlemen had to cut their
time
working time to be here way before
the streaming time begins and they left
here very late
sometimes they could come very they
could live very they could come but they
could come here very early
in the morning just to make sure that
all is well
thank you thank you thank you the
musicians
anybody who stood up to sing also
practiced
to sing i just want to say thank you
even before we started this campaign i'm
not i'm not going through my notes
we had the missionaries who came to
prepare the ground
they went from house to house knocking
the door and these missionaries came
from out of state
they worked for one week to prepare the
ground
we thank god for them wherever they are
thank you very
very very much our missionaries for this
campaign
allow me to thank even the people
who are doing the the testing outside
there the young people
they just come they are very excited i
want to take the temperature they just
take the temperature they tell you write
your name here this is the uh
the hand sanitizer these are the the
mask
and the decons usher us here inside
i was just sitting and watching and i
said
it is good to serve god
it is good to serve god therefore in a
in a nutshell i want to say
thank you very much for whoever dipped
his hand a hand in the pocket to support
this
campaign let me say thank you to the
speakers
pastor ekka thank you for the family
life
thank you very much and god bless you
camino el da camino you know
the health talk that was nice
and there's something i'm going to do
after this campaign about taking some
some those concussions and doing the
cleansing i'm going to do that and i
believe
at the end of it i will do it in the
next 15 years they say the
the cleaning of this internal system we
need to do that if you
did not listen to that message go back
to
to to the file and see what you're
supposed to do
and it is good for us especially as
brothers and sisters in christ to take
care of the inner system
thank you brother and your child doctor
for the financial you know
uh literacy message
we thank you we thank you very very much
allow me to thank the musicians
thank you god bless you
and also even those who prepare these
flowers and everything we can keep on
saying thank you and thank you but
uh finally i want to take to take this
moment
and thank pastor randy skeet busta
randy's kid came to town
in the twin cities in 2014
and a year after that in 2015
i called him i told him pastor randy
i want you to come back to the twin
cities
[Music]
and he told me the earliest time i can
come to
the twin cities is in 2020.
[Music]
you know he's always booked
if you want him to come to your place
you can say his there is
up to 20 2024 2025 there because this
is needed so i booked him almost five
years ago and
we kept on communicating and when i told
him that i'd come to faith church
district
and i said i want to introduce you to
the
my my my predecessor
[Music]
he said well you invited me
i would like to come where you are
and they said welcome and then
covey 19 came and i said should i cancel
the meeting if i cancel the next time
i'll get pastor randy to come to town
will be maybe in 2024. and i decided
let me just take a step of faith i
called the team and we started
of course we had voted way before but
we almost canceled we said we cannot do
these meetings during the covered 19.
and he came and he said i don't mind we
can preach
to our members and
when we started we were going to do
streaming of course
but we knew we were going to reach
around the twin cities
but we did not know that we will go far
and wide we did not know that
we'll be preaching to the far ends of
the world
and i thank god for second broadcasting
network brother bernard who is in
nairobi
he's been very very supportive and
brother duke through that networking
alone
by yesterday for three weeks over 180
000 people have watched this series
and we got the the numbers the the
the demographic of course we had more
senior more people over 40
35 and above who are watching more
female we had that
statistics on how people have watched
these meetings and that is only one
channel
we had another channel we had over six
different stations
alone like today alone
the morning service so far it has been
watched to close to almost 17 000
viewers today alone including
the baptism this one channel
adventist adventist youth for
for christ over 8 000 people
watched so we thank god
because of these you know
internet and online streaming and this
tells me that
the word of god will go faster than we
expected and
you know when we realized that things
were going the way it was going
we had to change honestly we had to
change
and that's why we we are and
[Music]
predominantly we're from kenya most of
our of us here
and we love swahili songs and we had to
change
to put more english songs and we spend
more time with the harmony sisters they
who have done a wonderful job
and we said let's put our hands for them
the harmony sisters
thank you thank you thank you they have
done so well for us in terms of music
thank you very much sister lennis who
did the first week
wonderful music she's an artist thank
you thank you she here by the way
all right wherever you are i know you'll
be told thank you very much and then our
brother abdallah came for a few days
and then a sister says faith momay
we thank you we've been blessed of
course with our pianist thank you very
much
god bless you i tonight
i would like pastor randy to see it come
on now these five days how many people
like to pass around to come back again
and we do these meetings
so tonight after the meetings
we'll go sit down i'll tell him now you
know you don't
talk anything about next appointment
until he finishes his assignment
so we'll sit down and i'll ask him
pastor randy can i see your diary
[Music]
and we would like to have a tradition
that next year
next year he'll come to ramsey for one
week
for a week of prayer we'll work that
and then after that at least i know we
can get a week for him
from him for next year because next day
so we'll squeeze him at least we get one
week
and then after that another one week
back
and then maybe in 2023 or we have
another
big evangelistic campaign we will be
having an evangelistic campaign
every year every year that is the work
god has given us that is the assignment
we have
other things are secondary so long as
i'm your pastor
my number one agenda is evangelism
telling people people about the good
news of the kingdom
telling people brothers and sisters
outside there
that jesus saves and with that
i thank you very much and i want to take
this moment
to to call pastor and before he comes to
speak to us
i'd like us to sing our theme song we've
been having that song
our theme song and then after that we
will hear the voice of pastor
randiskate who will give us the final
message and then
we'll declare our evangelistic campaign
officially crossed
call upon the choruses to lead us
in that song thank you very much again
[Music]
tell me that love
my hope is built
[Music]
holy
all other grounded
[Music]
his unchanging grace
[Applause]
[Music]
is
my soul gives way here then is
[Music]
is
found glad in his righteousness
[Music]
god is good and all the time
he really is psalm 100 verse 5 for the
lord
is good his mercy is everlasting
and his truth endureth to all
generations
i'd like to invite pastor ortim lentz to
come up with me
we will answer a few questions which
have been sent to us
and after that i will deliver the
message
and god is a god who likes to answer our
questions he also likes to ask
us questions as he did of adam where
thou and cain what has thou done
before we get into the question and
answer session let's pray
father in james chapter 1 verse 5 the
bible says
if any of you lack wisdom let him ask of
god
that giveth to all men liberally and
abridgeth not
and it shall be given him but let him
ask in faith
nothing withering for he that withereth
is as a wave of decree driven with the
wind and tossed
grant my brother and me this wisdom now
that we may represent the truth alright
in jesus name we pray
amen question one
question one
question one says freely you have
received freely
give that's matthew chapter 10 verse 8
and the question goes like this
can pastor randy's kids address on the
adventist
music ministry struck musicians
in praising god fame
money mission competition
and now that youtube has become the new
battlefield for adventist musicians
and video producers to square each other
on making money what does jesus say
concerning using god's talents
especially monetizing the christian
music
and summons especially by famous choirs
famous preachers like like you
one of your videos receives thousands of
views
in just a few days should the ministry
acquire
monetize and commercial commercialize
this digital product
online and receive money from these
recorded products
will this be the same like selling the
gospel
the bible does say freely have received
freely give but that's not all the bible
says
the bible says in first corinthians 9 14
even hath
god ordained he is required
that they which preach the gospel should
live off the gospel in first timothy
chapter 5
verse 17 the bible says
the elders that rule well let the elders
that rule well
be counted worthy of double honor
especially
they who labor in word and doctrine
verse 18 says for it is written
thou shalt not muzzle the ox that
treadeth out the corn
and the laborer is worthy of his reward
and so the bible makes it very clear
that those who preach the gospel must
live
off the gospel when the israelites
brought tithe in the wilderness
the sec the tithe was for the support of
the ministerial work
as represented by the work of the
priests and the levites
living off the gospel is not monetizing
the gospel
there are some preachers who turn the
church into a business
and paul talks about that and peter
talks about that
you're not monetizing the gospel god has
arranged
that those who preach the gospel should
live off the gospel
that's a different thing from saying
that the gospel becomes a business and
money is the focus no
money is never the focus now i since my
was mentioned i have never
ever charged a church for preaching
never in my life
and i never will i never say to a church
give me this amount and i'll come if you
call me and i have the time in my
schedule
i come if i don't have it i cannot come
i have never
sent a church a bill in my life
and i never will including
non-advertised churches where i've been
asked to speak
they ask me i go i speak if they say
here is a shilling
i say are you do you feel convicted if
they say yes
i say okay the lord will bless you i was
invited to speak at a baptist church a
few years ago in my
state of michigan when i was finished
the preacher handed me a check
and i looked at the size of the church
very small
and i looked at the check and i gave it
back to him and he almost fainted i said
no i can't take this
you use it somehow but i can't take this
money that's fine another baptist church
invited me to speak
once and the secretary called me and
said the church wants you to speak
what's your charge i said i have no
charge she said what i said i have no
charge you say well that's good for you
i am not speaking to any group without a
charge that's what she said
but i said i have no charge that's the
conviction god has laid on me
now some ministers have a charge and
that is fine
because they have biblical support for
that ministers must eat
ministers must pay rent ministers have
children so that is fine but
monetizing the gospel is something else
i don't know anything about youtube
youtube doesn't pay me any money if
they've paid me i've never seen it
and if they do i'll give god this tithe
youtube has never given me
one cent are you with me
i go places i preach people record their
messages
and make them into little cds and sell
them
and i have never said to anyone may i
have 10 percent of that
i don't even know i just know they do it
and that's it are you with me
and so those who preach the gospel
should live off the gospel
that's not the same thing as making the
gospel merchandise no no no
preachers must eat they must wear
clothes they must take care of their
families
now as far as musicians competing on
youtube i have no clue what that's
what's going on
what i do know is the church should
never fight in public
the church should ne it is better to
suffer a loss
than to engage in a public fight with
another member of the church whether
it's over music or whatever it is
the church must never well the church
shouldn't fight at all
but if it has to fight among itself we
must keep it within the family
never make our fights public it is
better as i said to
suffer a financial loss than to engage
in a public fisticuff over whatever
always protect the church always
with all its faults it is still the
object upon which god
pours out his supreme regard jesus had
12 disciples one was the devil
he said that himself in john 6 7 6 70.
have i not chosen you twelve
one of you is the devil jesus said in
explaining the parable of the sower and
the seed
he said let the where the wheat and the
tears grow together
the church has tears the church has we
the church has saints
the church has demons but it's still
god's church
are you with me never fight publicly
protect the church next question
thank you the next question is about
country living country living
what is really country living
if it's going to a remote area
how will one access medical care jobs
education and who will preach in the
city
if we all move to the country all right
country living is country living
you move to the country some rural area
away from the congestion of the city
where it is more fees more advantageous
to raising children
to your own spiritual life than the uh
the conditions that are obtained in the
city we know that city living
is convenient the gas station is just
down the street the supermarket
right over there the drugs are right
over there the bank we know that but
with regard to its effect on your
spiritual life the country living
is recommended when god made adam and
eve he placed them in a garden not in a
city the very first city was built by
the first
murderer cain in genesis chapter four
cain built the first city nimrod built
the first collection of cities into a
kingdom
god put adam in a garden a rural setting
ellen white the prophetess to this
church has recommended a long time ago
moved to the country she also recommends
think about it pray about it it must be
an individual decision not a mass exodus
each family must seek god's guidance and
wisdom as to how to proceed
when you are in the path of obedience to
god
the person said how will i contact
medical care or how will i work whatever
when you're the path of obedience to god
you've used your common sense
submitting your findings to the guidance
of the holy spirit the lord will take
care of that
are you with me now if we all move to
the country who will work in the city
loy tells us live in the country work in
the city
the cities must be worked but you don't
have to live in the city
and so she gives sound counsel there's a
book she's written a compilation it's
called
country living get that book and read it
country living and while accidents do
occur i know that
but following the health message will
reduce the likelihood of a need for a
doctor
i said accidents do happen because we
live in a sinful world
but you follow the health message you'll
be surprised
the effect on your body
okay thank you the next question
first of all they say happy sabbath my
brothers hope all is well
with you guys in the name of jesus
christ our lord and savior
i'm listening from toronto canada and i
have been
sharing on facebook god is good
and faithful to god be the glory for the
great things he has
done and is still still doing thank god
for the many souls that have
accepted the call of god this is a
wonderful series i
myself have been renewed and
my have been renewed
from the messages i've heard i believe
thank you for the inspiration for the
series and may god continue to bless you
all
especially thank you to pastor and
sketch for these timely messages of
encouragement
much love guys question can we
say that sometimes our attitudes are
controlled
by unconscious bias yes
a lot of racism is practiced not
consciously
unconsciously people don't wake up and
decide today i choose to be a racist
a lot of what we do that's wrong happens
unconsciously
because we do not monitor our thinking
and our behavior
now sin is the source of all of that
so the question is can our biases be the
result of unconscious bias or behaviors
yes yes yes
much of it is unconscious but it's no
less real because it's unconscious
christians must live very consciously we
must live
purposefully we must live deliberate
lives
the christian cannot live his or her
life on automatic pilot that's for
airplanes
we must consciously decide i'll do
what's right today we must consciously
decide
i will not deal unfairly with this
person that person based on how he or
she looks
we must consciously decide every day
that we will try to behave like jesus
christ it must be
conscious it cannot be left to
unconscious urges
because then we will go wrong because
our strongest unconscious
urge is the urge to sin so we must be
conscious deliberate intentional
purposeful christians aware of what
we're doing
and why
thank you pastor the fourth question
probably the last one how do we
as a church accept the homosexuals
and love them should we allow
them to participate in church activities
the homosexual the lesbian the adulterer
the fornicator the child abuser
the thief the carjacker christ died for
all sinners
if the church knows there's a practice
in child abuser that person cannot work
in children's ministries are you with me
we're not condemning that person but
that behavior puts you and other people
at risk
so wherever the behavior of the
christian puts
people at risk then that person cannot
be placed in that office of service
the church also believes contrary to
many places in the united states
that ban what is called conversion
therapy
the belief that a homosexual cannot be
changed is very popular
a lesbian cannot be changed that's the
way he or she is
in a bible commentary volume 6 page 1101
paragraph 3 ella white writes
god makes no compromise with sin
genuine conversion changes hereditary
and cultivated tendencies to wrong
listen again
genuine conversion changes
hereditary you inherited it and
cultivated by constant practice
tendencies to wrong homosexuality in a
person
can be changed by the power of god
regardless of what the states
say because with god nothing
shall be impossible as long as
calvary's cross has blood on it that
person can change what is required
is a genuine surrender to god
the greatest expression the greatest
urge
is not homosexual behavior it is sin
and god requires that to be conquered
are you with me
and everything else flows from sin if
god
requires the conquest of sin he requires
the conquest of homosexual behavior
or lesbian behavior or whatever other
behavior is demonstrated by a person
the church is a place where people are
told
there is power to change
regardless of the area of weakness there
is power to change and that power
is expressed or is found in
a man who's also god called
jesus christ now we must respect the
laws of the land
in some states like i believe california
ohio oregon
it is illegal to practice conversion
therapy the church does not practice
conversion therapy
the church preaches the gospel are you
with me and the gospel is
god has found a way to deliver us
from the tyranny and the slavery of
every sin we can imagine and so the
church deals with members
and if members are unfit for an office
regardless of the area of unfitness
that person is not allowed to serve it
is this this
exclusion is not reserved for homosexual
lesbians for
anyone whose behavior and conduct known
to the church
unfits that person for service but again
i must say
the church is a place where efforts are
made to show people
that jesus can change you
and there are those who have been
changed who can testify
i used to be that way now i'm this first
corinthians 6
verse 9 11 and 10 paul says such were
some of you
but you are justified you are sanctified
he said some of you were homosexuals
some of you were lesbians but jesus
changed you if he changed them then he
can change them now
is that it all right let's pray
father thank you for this session we
hope that the words spoken
have been a blessing to someone take all
the glory father
and continue to work vigorously god
to change lives and save them in jesus
name we pray
amen thank you pastor
let me say quickly because god must
always be the focus
i have been honored to be here i've been
highly blessed
i thank my pastor that's makua for
inviting me
i'm grateful for the very great kindness
of pastor fred
pastor otim all the others who
came in contact with me i will go away
with not
one complaint did you hear me
not one i thank god for the mokayah
family where i've been staying
god knows how i am and he arranged for
me the perfect setting
may god bless that family to high heaven
from this day forward until jesus comes
and may he save every member of that
family
while i'm saying that to them if there's
anyone online watching
and you've kept me in your home as i
have been on god's business
may the lord continue to bless you bless
your families
and admit your children ahead of you
into his kingdom
thank you brother charles thank you
sister leah thank you pauline who have
not yet met
thank you jackson have not yet met and
thank you my brother dr david wherever
he is
thank you thank you thank you for
opening your palace to me
you shall live in my heart and i will
pray for you as long
as i live i have some very special
little friends who always come and check
on me
i don't know where they are but they
come wherever i am and they check on me
uh sister elvira
she raised her hand right there where is
my little brother benjamin i don't know
where he is but benjamin keeps waving at
me every 10 seconds he says hi
i was chatting with maria i don't know
where she is where'd maria go
ah there's maria god bless the little
children who made my life so happy
i mean it god bless them and the bigger
children
and the bigger children and the adult
children thank you
very much for your affection i really
mean that
and when i go i shall go with a heart
full of sweet sweet memories
like a bouquet of roses in my heart
every petal is a lovely memory
god bless you and do everything you can
to hold on to jesus you know let me pray
father in heaven
i'm just making these remarks you may
turn them into the sermon i'm not sure
but let the spirit speak through me
father and let me do everything in my
power to glorify
you in jesus name i pray amen
in first timothy chapter 6 12 and i'm
leaving this with you
timothy paul told timothy fight
the good fight of faith you don't sit on
a couch and go to heaven
are you with me there's an adversary
there is an enemy who puts up roadblocks
and so
paul tells timothy fight
the good fight of him lay hold on
eternal life in other words
don't just hold it like that anyone can
snatch this out of your hand
hold it like this then put it right here
no one can get it
hold lay hold he said on eternal life
but we only lay hold on that which we
value highly
are you following me we must value
salvation we must value
jesus jesus is salvation and so
paul told timothy fight
the good fight of faith young man wrote
me he said pastor i'm caught up in
certain sin which will go unmentioned
and i wrote back i said listen
you have to fight because you're
fighting for your life
remember joseph not joseph jacob at
midnight
by that stream when someone touched him
on his shoulder what did he start to do
he started to fight you know he was
fighting with god
and he fought the bible says all night
then the person said let me go and jacob
said no because he realized who he was
struggling with
he was fighting for his life god touched
his hip
and dislocated the hip he kept fighting
on one foot
and for the rest of his life he limped
sometimes contact with god
leaves a physical mark to remind you who
gave it to you but he gave it to you for
your salvation
and i say to you fight the good fight of
faith
in uh galatians chapter 5 verse 17 for
the flesh
lusteth against the spirit and the
spirit against the flesh
and these are contrary one to the other
in other words paul is saying is a
constant battle
constant battle even in the converted
person
there is a constant battle and that
battle will only
end when this mortal puts on immortality
and his corruptable puts on in
corruption and so
paul told timothy fight the good fight
of faith
james gives us some advice and james was
the half-brother of jesus
in james chapter 4 verse 10 here's what
he tells us
submit yourself therefore to god
resist the devil and he will
flee we need to see the devil running
more often
not to us but away from us
james gives a step number one submit
yourself therefore to god
and that's a mission must be total
submit your profession to god submit
your children to god
submit your financial life to god submit
your home to god
submit your love life to god let the
submission be complete
without a complete submission god cannot
save you or me
and so james the half-brother of jesus
tells us
submit yourself therefore to god then he
says
resist the devil and he will flee the
word
resist is an action word resist
it takes effort you know i love going to
the gym lifting is my favorite exercise
is something called a deadlift
and i just love the deadlift man you've
got to make effort
you do three reps or 400 pounds and you
you have made an effort because you have
resist you have to resist something
called
inertia inertia is a tendency of an
object to stay where it is
are you with me you've got to say no no
no no i'm going to
lift you off the ground
it takes your energy and after three
repetitions that's it and you go sit
down for
three minutes to catch your breath and
recover james tells us resist the devil
and he will flee he'll take a vacation
now he'll come back let him flee again
and so we have fight the good fight of
faith
i used to work in a medical school many
years ago as a counselor
and i would counsel phd students they're
doing md phd
and md by itself is enough torture a phd
by itself and any science is torture
they're doing combined first years of
medicine next three years of phd
then back to medicine for two years take
about seven eight nine years
and they'd come to my office the
experiment didn't work
and they stay in the laboratory the lab
many many years
nights late nights not go home some
would sleep in the lab
because they were fighting that
experiment had to work
so they can get results and publish a
paper
and so they were fighting the good fight
of scientific research
they made a sacrifice some homes broke
up
all night in the library i saw couples
come to medical school they came married
left divorce
because they were each under so much
stress but the medical degree was
important to them
and so they put the effort they made the
sacrifice
it cost them the bible says
fight turn off that tv
get off social media for a while if
you're not conducting any worthwhile
ministry
make an effort and god will bless your
effort
with his power ella white writes in the
work of redemption
god requires the cooperation of man
you must work with god for your
salvation
in revelation john tells us behold i
come quickly
hold that fast which thou has that no
man take that crown
revelation 3 11 behold i come quickly
this is christ
hold that fast
that no man if you have a dog you give
the dog a bone
have you ever tried taking the bone out
of the dog's mouth
that dog will start to growl because
you're messing with his livelihood are
you following me
the dog will hold if you have a pet lion
because none of you do but and you do
don't go
close to the lion when you feed him feed
him from a distance
because the moment you throw that meat
that lion changes personality
and starts to growl and he protects that
meat
he does not want to share that meat with
another lion or a hyena or human being
this is his meat and so the bible tells
us behold i come quickly
hold that fast
hold on to what you have hold on to this
that's christ forgiven you hold on to
the forgiveness by avoiding
sin has god blessed your life with some
insight into his word
hold on to it by studying it and living
life accordance with god has shown you
we have to learn to hold on
because there's a power opposing you
hold on look at the words again fight
the good fight of faith someone
wrote me and said uh i'm trying to
conquer this particular sin
uh it occurs when such and such comes
close to me this lady
i wrote back and said well tell the lady
don't come close to you
or stay away from her if her presence
contributes to your weakness
avoid her the way job avoided sin here
is how god described job in job chapter
1 verse 8 let me pray again
father in heaven speak through me very
clearly dear god
that your people may be blessed by your
word in jesus name i pray
amen and the lord said unto satan hast
thou
considered my servant job there is none
like him in the earth let me pause on
that isn't that a beautiful testimony
from god
about a human being there are some
testimonials god has given in the bible
that
are so beautiful and i covet them
when god spoke abraham he said i know
him
that he will command his children and
his household after him i know that man
i can trust him to lead his family and
god told satan
hast thou considered my servant job
there is
none like him in the earth and this is
god testifying to the character of job
or that god will say that about me
when god looks down on minnesota
minneapolis or
champlain or brooklyn park or winnie
tonka or is it minnetonka
or ramsay let him say have you ever seen
the ramsest dear church
there is no church like that church have
you seen kcc
you seen this young man
there is no young man like him i can
turn my back
and i know he's not embarrassing me
there's none like him there's none like
him in the earth
a perfect and an upright man one that
feareth god
and esther with evil the fancy word s2
means to avoid
and so i told this young man avoid the
person
who endangers your spiritual life
this other young fellow wrote me as i
broke up with this girl but we're still
in touch and there we fight i said look
jesus said if your right hand offends
you do what two things what are the two
things
cut it off come on cast it from you
this is no joke cut it off
and then throw it away
if you're in a relationship that has
intention your spiritual life
cut it off
somebody say amen and leave it cut off
and then toss it away i've spoken to so
many young people who are in mixed
relationships
adventists not adventists i said look
break it off
tonight you call him i'll talk to him
for you
i was in mombasa doing a
camp meeting i was counseling this young
lady came to me uh maybe 28-27
i have a boyfriend he's not adventist
i said you got to break it off i don't
need details is the adventist no break
it off don't give me a speech
break it off we've been together three
years we're three years late in breaking
it off
i said she said how can i do that i said
call him i'll talk to him
so she called him and he came to the
campground and he stood right there
she stood right there and i spoke to him
listen to what i told him
shook his hand says nice to meet you a
handsome young man
she has made a mistake and deceived you
she has caused you to believe that this
church
favors this kind of relationship and it
does not she's wrong
you did nothing right all you did was
exercise good taste
and he shook my hand he said pastor i
understand
i prayed and he left and they never got
back together again
are you following me anything that
endangers
your eternal life cut it off and
cast it from you if you are in that
situation right now with that guilty
smile on your face
break it call the pastor the elder come
with me
and go announce i was wrong i was at a
church in a certain city new york
preaching this young lady came to me
pray for my boyfriend
i said uh why he won't come to church
i said but why wouldn't your boyfriend a
nice faithful vegetarian adventist
not come to church and she said
he's not an adventist i said oh okay
here's what i'll pray for i will pray
that you will apologize to god
for misleading him into thinking this is
okay
she turned away and walked away
anything that endangers your eternal
life
get rid of it not your husband of course
or your wife but
anything else get rid of it are you with
me
come on say your man all right what
words have we looked at
fight the good fight of faith where's
that text found i told you
come on come on we haven't got all day
where's the text found
first timothy 6 12
paul said fight and timothy was as a
matter of fact
timothy was a teenager when paul called
him to work
young men don't wait until you're 28
serve god at 14
13 12 16. don't just spend your life
playing video games and watching
basketball
god needs your energy and your youth
and so we're to fight the good fight of
faith what was the next word we talked
about
resist where's that text found
not genesis no james yes
what chapter what verse seven
but what's the word that comes before
resist submit yourself to god
resist the devil and he will flee from
you now
here's something else go to john 15 john
15.
john 15 god bless you for loving god for
loving his word and i address these
remarks to you in this building
and to god's people watching via the
internet thank you very much
for joining night after night day after
day i really mean it
it was my honor to bring god's word to
you john 15
reading from verse one jesus speaking
let me pray father please
restrain me and let your spirit have his
way in jesus name i plead and
implore amen i am the true vine
and my father is the husband man every
branch in me
that beareth not fruit he taketh away
by the way i think i've said this before
it is the father that gets rid of
useless branches
so when you decide to leave the church
because you're badly treated
no one can get you to leave the church
if you truly love christ
are you with me no one can get you to
leave the church
you can join another church of the same
congrega same denomination
but no one can get you to leave jesus
unless you choose to leave jesus
jesus said every branch in me that
beareth not fruit he taketh away
and every branch that beareth through he
purges it that it may bring forth more
fruit
now read verse 3 of john 15.
come on if you have the king james
version nice and loud now
ye are clean how through the word come
on
the dog which i have spoken unto you now
we have resist
we have fight we have hold on and we
have
the word nothing will cleanse your mind
like the word not a course in psychology
from the university of champlain
but the word of god will cleanse
your mind it is a cleansing agent and so
jesus told the disciples ye are
clean through the word which i
have spoken unto you how does god
cleanse the church
ephesians 5 let's read from verse 25
ephesians 5 reading from verse 25
i should have told you i read from the
king james version
of the bible do you have ephesians 5
reading verse 25 listen and read
microscopically
are you there husbands love your wives
all husbands amen
that was weak but that's okay husbands
love your wives
even as christ also loved the church and
gave himself for it
that he might sanctify and cleanse it
now you read for me
with the washing of
by the word the washing of water by the
word
so he cleanses the church through the
the word has a cleansing effect on the
mind
go to psalm 119 let's read verse
9 every young person should know this
verse from memory
very short very powerful psalm 119
verse 9 it says this wherewithal shall a
young man cleanse his ways
by taking his thereto according to thy
word
the bible is saying how can a young man
clean up his life
it's very sad that the young life has to
be cleaned up but that's the case in
which the
world in which we live the bible says by
taking heed thereto
according to thy word young man young
woman old man old woman
it is the same the word of god is the
cleansing agent
christ object lessons page 100 paragraph
one
ellen white writes if studied and
obeyed you know that's my favorite word
the word of god
works in the heart subduing every unholy
attribute
now think of those words if studied
and obeyed someone wrote me
very early this year my spiritual life
is declining
i have no interest in spiritual things
church reading praying i i know god is
good i love him but i just
have lost interest i sent her bible
passage to read
and analyze and answer questions for me
i told her i said pray read the passage
several times
when you read shut out every possible
distraction
so just you and that word existing in
the universe you and that word nothing
else exists
read it then read it again then read it
five times
minimum ask the spirit of god to
direct your thinking then answer this
question
she wrote back i am revived
send me more studies so girl you study
for yourself
i am revived she said this is amazing
the word of god is designed to revive
you
it's designed to clean you up and so the
servant of god says
if studied and obeyed
the word of god works in the heart
subduing every unholy
attribute jesus was praying to his
father
and he said sanctify them
through thy truth finish the verse thy
word
is truth now jesus told the father
sanctify his disciples
we know from first thessalonians chapter
4 verse 3 and this
is the will of god even your
sanctification
if the will of god is our sanctification
and first john 5 14 says if we ask
anything according to his will he
heareth us
and if jesus prayed that prayer anything
jesus prays the father answered
then we have a prayer from jesus
for our sanctification
he said do it through the word i'll tell
you something else go to john 17
let's read verse 9. john 17
verse 9 if this does not make you feel
good i don't know what will
john 17 reading verse 9.
let's read from verse 8 then we go to 9.
john 17 8 and 9.
then we go to 22
20 20. after we go 8-9 for i have given
unto them the words which thou gives me
and they have received them and have
known surely that i came out from thee
and they have believed that thou they
send me now verse nine very carefully
i pray for them
i pray not for the world
stop jesus says
i am praying for them
the disciples you know at that moment
he's not praying for the world i pray
for them
i pray not for the world but for them
which that has given me for their thine
and all mine are thine and thine of mine
jesus said
i prayed for them now you may say yes
but that was 2 000 years ago
go to verse 20.
now if you have the king james version
you read it out loud for me what does
this say
neither pray i for these
come on but for them also we shall
believe
on me so jesus is saying all those who
accept the gospel down to the ages
this prayer covers them do you
understand what this means to you
jesus prayed for you
ah that amen is weak i said jesus prayed
for you
now your mother has prayed for you god
bless her my mother prayed for me all
the days of her life since i was born
and i credit god first from my spiritual
position and my mother my mother
she's resting in her grave but my mother
she prayed for her children and i thank
god for that
and if my mother and i come to the
heavenly gates and there's one space
left
give it to her without hesitation
jesus prayed for you remember when
jesus said to peter simon simon satan
hath desired to have you
that he may sift you as wheat what are
the next few words jesus says
but i come on have prayed for thee that
thy faith fail not wait a minute
jesus prayed for peter
that prayer is for us you're saying amen
because you're nice
but do you understand what you're saying
amen for who is jesus
he's god what did he do
he created heaven and earth by his word
what else did he do he died on calvary
he is god
he is creator he's always been there
he conquered death he raised himself
from the grave
he told peter
i have prayed for you
that thy faith fail not question for you
if jesus prayed that prayer to the
father for peter
will the father answer that prayer yes
now
john 17 20 neither pray i for these
alone
but for them also we shall believe on me
through the word
jesus prayed for you do not disappoint
his prayer
right where you sit you are covered by
the prayer
of your savior he cannot force you you
can choose by your lifestyle or i can't
but by ins and step away from the
covering of that prayer
but if you and i will hold on to jesus
that
prayer he offered in john 17 will
continue
to cover us
fight the good fight of faith
submit yourself to god resist the devil
avoid circumstances that put your
salvation in peril
this is the cleansing agent
and jesus offered a prayer for you
i pray for them i pray not for the world
my brothers and sisters how could you
lose with the word of god on your side
how can you
lose with jesus praying for you
how can you lose with a father who
answers any prayer
that jesus offered when jesus prays
father
spirit and son are all on your side
we have the resources to conquer
we have what is required to live a life
that glorifies god
and embarrasses the devil
one of the thing you need to understand
let's look at the very
first promise of the bible the first
genesis 3 verse 15 you should say it
without looking
but i'll be merciful genesis 3 verse 15
let me pray again father i'm soon to end
my remarks continue to speak through me
god
and bless your lovely people gathered in
this building and on the internet
in jesus name i pray amen genesis
3 15 and i will put enmity between thee
and the woman
between thy seed and her seed it shall
bruise thy head and thou shalt bruise
his heel
listen to that verse microscopically
i that's god we'll put hatred in you
for the things of the devil
you know why god has to do that and i
told you that a few weeks a few days ago
because of adam we are born with enmity
toward god
god says wait a minute i need to switch
that enmity around
i will put enmity in you for the things
of the devil
and the opposite effect will be you will
have love
for me ask god
to give you hatred for gambling
if that's your weakness ask god say
father
you said always confront the confront is
not a good word
always present god's word to him for
instance if well let me continue with
this
ask god to take selfishness out of your
heart
all of this are expressions of enmity
against god
ask him take out of me selfishness
laziness this constant avoiding of god's
word
take it out of me and replace it
with the love for god a love for his
word
a love for prayer a love for witnessing
a love for kindness a love for
generosity
the very first promise of the bible
is a promise from god to put hatred in
the heart
for the things of the devil when you
pray i was saying
present god with his word for instance
let's say one of your children left the
church
you pray to god you go to second peter
chapter three verse nine
the lord is not slack concerning his
promise as some men count slackness
but is long suffering to us word not
willing that any should perish if your
son's name is john
and he left the church father you said
you're not willing that john should
perish
if you mean it do everything necessary
to bring him back
not for my sake but for your sake
because you're not willing
that john should perish father my
husband loves me
he's very nice but he he needs to
understand the truth
you say father you said in first timothy
chapter 2 verse 4
you will have all men to be saved and to
come
unto the knowledge of the truth if you
want him to know the truth
reveal it to him i pray remind god
of what he said you say father you said
bring all the tithe into the storehouse
that there may be meat in mine house
and prove me now here with save the lord
of hosts
if i will not open you the windows of
heaven
do you understand what open you the
windows of heaven mean go to genesis 7
let me show you what that means
genesis 7 we're talking about using
god's word when you pray
god may ignore your words he will never
ignore his
genesis 7 reading verse 11.
in the 600 year of noah's life
in the second month the 17th day of the
month
the same they were all the founders of
the great deep broken up finish the
verse
and the windows of heaven what
what came down the flood
you see when god made the earth he
separated water
here was the earth there was water on
the earth in the earth and above the
earth
and so the earth was in a sort of a
greenhouse arrangement you understand
to protect the earth from the harmful
rays coming in from space
they're harmful to us but they have
their function in god's system let me
say it again
if you read don't go there just listen
second peter 3 5 for this they willingly
are ignorant of
that by the word of god the heavens were
of old and the earth standing
out of the water and in the water
there's water under the earth
there's water on the earth and there was
water above the earth
when god sent the flood he brought down
he brought up water from underneath
he brought down water from above so much
the bible says
the highest mountains were covered now
the highest mountains keep this image in
mind
and listen to malachi 310 bring me all
the tithe into the storehouse
that there may be meat in my house and
prove me now here with lord of hosts
if i will not open you the windows of
heaven
and pour you out a blessing they shall
not be rude enough to receive it
the same with that flood covered every
mountaintop
when god blesses the faithful tithe
giver or tithe returner
god will bless you to cover every need
you have somebody say amen
i didn't say every luxury you desire i
said every need you
have god will cover it because he said
so
and covered 19 does not change the word
of god
are you following me god's promises are
sure
regardless of sociological conditions
and so when you pray to god
you say you said
that's what you said now if i had said
it father i understand
but you said and your word in titus 1
says which god that cannot lie
your word says in numbers 23 19 god is
not a man that he shall lie
you said
now stand by your word of course you say
that with respect
and watch what god but god will also say
but you also said i will follow thee my
save
you said that what happened to that
you said that what happened to that you
said give me the bible
you said that what happened to that
you're so busy with work in school and
children and boyfriends you have no time
for that which gives you
life let me tell you something and i'll
stop let me pray again father
i'll close give me a straight message
for your people please
father and restrain my carnal nature in
jesus name
amen how many of you have ever sent up a
prayer request to god can i see your
hand
or give one to pastor yes do you know
god has prayer requests
we're always giving prayer requests to
people pray for this pray for that
and i travel all over the world by god's
grace and i get sheets of prayer
requests and i pray for all of them
god has prayer requests but nobody asks
him what his prayer requests are
here's a prayer request from god pray
every morning
and every night at least god says listen
world i have another prayer requests
give me my tithe that's god
and god is on his knees for years
praying please give me my tithe
and stop hurting yourself stop living on
the curse
god has prayer requests gather your
children every day
and have family worship even if you get
to work late
that's god's prayer request god has
another prayer request
stop fighting among yourselves because
it's a bad example of the community
god has prayer requests let's answer his
god has prayer requests stop drinking
alcohol secretly
stop smoking secretly
stop living your life on the internet on
sites that are dirty and nasty and
impure
that's god's prayer request now let's
grant god's prayer requests
young man god has a prayer request for
you since that young lady became your
girlfriend
is she closer to god or further from god
is she closer to her parents or always
fighting her parents
is she at risk being your girlfriend god
has a prayer request
have the right influence on my daughter
what did i say fight the good fight of
faith
what else did i say resist but before
resist
submit resist what did i say about the
word
it cleanses what did i say about
something that's an offense to you
cut it off and throw it away throw it so
far
it never comes back like azzazeel on the
day of atonement
what else did i say when you pray to god
do what
present god with his word
with his word you said you said
you said and god will never
back away from his word but
listen now when god says now here's what
i want you to do
a relationship is not a one-way street
it goes two ways god said okay send your
request to me how many do you have two
million okay fine i only have three
pray study the word
and wrap that all up the one word obey
me
let me close by telling you this the
person
who obeys god will incur
no regrets
the world may think you're suffering let
me say it again
the person who commits his or her life
to obey god from the heart
will incur no regrets
there are no regrets for serving god
young people you're 17 18.
if jesus doesn't come you get to 30 and
40 the quality of your life then
will depend on the decisions and choices
you make now
put your life in the life in the hand of
god
he'll take care of it and you look back
and you may see no regrets or very few
and the ones you have will be small
because god knows how to manage the life
and so as i leave
you i call upon you in the name of jesus
in the name of jesus
live your life for the glory of god
there is a bible verse we tend to take a
symbolic it's not
whether therefore he eat
or drink come on finish it or whatsoever
he do finish the verse do all
which means let me ask you this if you
do something directly for god's glory
is that a spiritual act yes
some of you didn't get it let me ask
again if you do
something chiefly for the glory of god
is that a spiritual act the answer is
yes
now the bible says do
everything for the glory of god
then our lives should be one constant
spiritual life
when you work listen to ephesians 6 5
servants be obedient to them that are
your masters
according to the flesh with fear and
trembling
in singleness of your heart as unto
christ
work as if you're working for christ
is that a spiritual act yes
if your work is to repave the highway
the bible says whatsoever thy hand
findeth to do finish it for me do it
with thy might
that's a spiritual which means
excellence is spiritual behavior
ah come on say amen excellence
is spiritual behavior young men young
women you want to be spiritual in the
classroom
pursue excellence
it is not an act it's a state of mind
in psalm 106 verse 3 blessed are they
that keep judgment
and he that doeth righteousness at
all times
there's something i love to tell god's
people you've probably heard it before
what time is it can someone tell me the
time what time is it if someone has a
watch
a clock what time is it
6 21 6 25 somewhere around 6 25 when
does the sun set
eight all right when what was that
whenever it says it's all right when the
sun sets listen to me carefully
what comes to an end the sabbath
the holy day in the bible a day begins
at sunset
when the listen to me carefully when the
sun sets
the sabbath the holy day is over
but you are still a holy person the sun
does not set on your holiness
so whatever plans you have for tonight
when the sun sets
now that you know it does not set on
your holiness you may have to change
them somebody say amen
you may have to change them because
you're required to be holy how many days
of the week
how many hours case closed
that's living consciously
blessed are they that do righteousness
at all
times first timothy chapter 4 verse 8
but bodily exercise profiteth little
but godliness is profitable
unto all things having promise of the
life that now
is and of the life to come
godliness righteousness right doing
has benefits now and the benefits extend
into the life to come
i'm gonna close don't panic but you need
to understand this
when jesus comes a curtain does not come
down on your life
and then you start a new life you start
a new life physically
you don't start a new life morally
the very first day we spend in heaven
will be no different
from the last day we spent on earth
let me say differently we must live as
if we're in heaven now
before we actually get there is that
clear now we must live
now and so i say again when christ comes
he does not bring down a curtain and
said okay this life is over and this one
starts
the curtain does not come down on the
character
we move into heaven with the same
we had when jesus came down the skies
we have to live it now
this is the power let me speak to anyone
of any age
make an effort to memorize some verses
make an effort i have a friend in
kenya god bless kenny all the kenyans
why kenya she's a grandmother
very precious friend of mine i won't
call her name i know she's listening
lovely family ah the family lives right
here
my heart is full of family and
still room for more and i told her why
don't you try memorizing some verses
she was hesitant i believe at first now
she's
she once did the first 10 chapters of
proverbs can you ima
now it's it's memorizing proverbs is a
challenge because each verse is almost
different from the other
are you following me i mean you memorize
daniel chapter two
there's a story but proverbs every verse
seems to be independent
so it's a real challenge but she went
through the first 10 chapters
and then john this and john that and
she's been memorizing i have another
friend in kenya
i said why don't you memorize some
verses person started
john 14 then john this and then john
that
and then first john and i said listen
these chapters are fine why don't you
memorize a book
memorize the book of jonah
you have a mind that was designed
to study god's word and memorize it now
will it be a challenge at first yes
we have a saying practice makes perfect
have you heard that saying yes
that's how professional football players
are so good at basketball or baseball or
football
or hockey or whatever now in
mind character and personality volume 2
page 601 paragraph 4 ella white writes
that which at first seems difficult by
constant repetition grows easy
i want you to memorize the bible first
right now it'll take you five seconds or
less
fewer are you ready first thessalonians
17 pray without ceasing say back to me
you just memorized the verse now if you
can memorize
that three words
then find a verse that has four words
are you following
let's memorize another verse john 11 35
jesus wept
make a tremendous effort and say back to
me
you just had another verse you strained
your brain and you said it
jesus swept three words let's try a
longer one
prove all things hold fast that which is
good let me hear it
yes try
you'll be excited and the presence of
the word
in your head will assist you
in dealing with spiritual challenges if
you read
the sermon on the day of pentecost in
acts chapter 2
one third of that sermon is old
testament quotations
peter did not have a bible
you read all the sermons in the book of
acts peter paul
james whomever they all have old
testament quotations they did not
carry bibles they were not bibles to
carry back then if there's a scroll
it's in the synagogue remember luke 4 16
and jesus as his custom was went up into
the synagogue
and sat down and he was lived unto him
to scroll and he read
that's what the bible was you better
thank god everyone has a bible today
even though it's not read make an effort
and i recommend to you the book of john
because john tells us he wrote that book
so that those who read it
will have eternal life and he was the
closest disciple to jesus
he lived the longest and ella white says
of all the disciples
he was the one who most closely
reflected the character of jesus read
the gospel of john
that's where john 3 16 is say john 3 16
for me
god bless you forever put the word of
god in your heart
teach it to your children
teach it now who can
uh give me all 66 books from genesis
revelation
in order all 66.
don't raise your hands altogether the
same time who can
oh come yes come come come
come all 66 then i'll pray
teach the children you'll be surprised
how quickly they learn they will learn
these things
but don't tell them go and learn it you
teach them so you are involved
come how are you
you look like a nice boy what's your
what's your name wesley
wesley's a good name how old are you 10.
jesus was 10.
he was a good boy are you a good boy say
yes
yes wesley
genesis of revelation here you go
genesis
exodus leviticus numbers
jude ruth deuteronomy
joshua numbers
[Music]
job sam's
proverbs ecclesiastics
songs of solomon
isaiah
jeremiah limitation
ezekiel daniel
hosea joe
matthew mark matthew mark luke and john
acts romans limitations ezekiel
first first corinthians second
corinthians
galatians ephesians
philippians collagens
first 2 thessalonians
first john first timothy 2 timothy
titus violina hebrews
james first peter
ii peter first john
ii john third john
jude revelation
thank you professor okay god bless you
let me tell you a little secret it is
one thing to note when you're sitting in
the pew
it is something altogether different to
come and stand here
everything goes off your head and flies
to heaven and so god bless my young
brother god bless him
how many of you will say lord i recommit
my life to you
hold me and guide me can i see your
right hand
stand with me
before i pray i'm gonna invite you to
give me prayer requests
not little sermons just pray requests
are you with me make them
short and to the point
this side any prayer requests just raise
your hand and tell me
what's her name nicole how old is she
oh okay yes my young brother
yes okay all right anybody else yes
sister
pray for your children to come to christ
when you speak lord your mask
anybody else on this side no no no no
yes sister
[Music]
your children to accept christ okay
children are precious
isaiah 49 25 i will save thy children
this side oh yes my little sister
pray for everyone who's sick okay yes
we'll do that yes
pray for him oh yes thank you very much
yes yes anybody else
yes my brother okay my sister
your brothers
your friend's baby oh
no jesus was a baby god has a special
place in his heart for babies okay
yes my brother
your brother's drinking okay
he used to preach he can come back and
preach
he can come back solomon walked with god
then he left then he came back yes
sister
oh yes go ahead
you know what
freedom of oh yes it won't last forever
yes
okay yes sister
yahoo pray for your sister
pray for whom her sister
and mother
oh the sister's name is martha
okay all right thank you yes did i see
your hand no
yes
okay all right okay yes sister
your brother your children
speak loudly your family okay yes my
young brother
okay what's his name
julian okay all right
anybody else yes my brother
for whom
oh yes yes yes yes yes yes my brother
lower that mask
your family all right yes yes sister
the orphans oh yes yes orphans
yes
your friends carmen who came that the
spirit will continue to work on heart
yes we're in the back
yes yes the hold on the devil will try
to discourage you
hold on and you hold on by holding on to
this by faith
because jesus is the word all right
anything else
all right let us kneel and i'll pray
father in heaven we come before you
in the name of jesus jesus said if he
shall ask anything
in my name i will do it
but he also says if he abide in me
and my words abide in you you shall ask
what he will
and it shall be done unto you
his word also says and whatever we ask
we receive of him
because we keep his commandments and do
those things which are right in his
sight
his word also says whosoever shall turn
away his ear from hearing the law
even his prayer shall be an abomination
his word also says if i regard iniquity
in my heart
the lord will not hear me
now father we kneel before you we come
before you
in the name of sinless jesus
the one who said let there be light
the one who said at the tomb of lazarus
i am the resurrection and the life
the one who said on the cross it is
finished
the one who said at the open grave o
death where is thy sting
o grave where is thy victory the one who
said
i will come again and receive you unto
myself
in his name we come to you father
if we have misrepresented you today
on the strength of the sacrifice of
jesus
forgive us with the removal of sin
replace it with a hatred for sin which
is to say a
love for jesus and what he will have us
to do
may god change our hearts i pray
because everything proceeds from the
heart
change our hearts give us a new one and
a new spirit
we recommit our lives to your loving
father
we're so sorry for the many times we've
disappointed you we
recommit our lives regardless of age
they got we
recommit our lives to you now and we ask
your father
to pay attention to all the prayer
requests that were mentioned you heard
them
you knew them before they were spoken
their prayers for children to come to
christ
for those who are sick for unity in the
church
someone in the hospital father parents
praying for children spouses praying for
each other
whatever the requests were father you
heard them and there were many unspoken
request
in the name of jesus god do something
father
do something to god move in the lies of
your people
who have been listening to your word
move in their lives father
you're a good god your word says he
maketh his son to rise
on the evil and on the good and sendeth
reign
on the just and on the unjust father if
you'll be so gracious to the unjust
and the evil what about how you deal
with us your people
jesus said behold the fowls of the air
they sow not
neither do they reap nor gather into
barns yet your heavenly father feedeth
them
are ye not much better than they god
take care of us father
provide for us god let us do all we can
but
not at the risk of endangering our
relationship with you
please bless every family father a
double blessing on the children their
god
unite the spouses father let every home
be a little heaven on earth
let the light of jesus christ shine from
every earth
and every home and from every heart
father
bless the leadership of faith
international
and ramsey and kcc wherever your people
are in this city
bless the leadership father but from my
point of view bless pastor mccoy in a
very special way
give him wisdom from above their god
because
leadership is not easy moses is the
outstanding example of that
let's pass over to him pastor fred all
those working with the pastor to
manage this church and ramsay bless them
god and let their example
lift the congregations i personally
thank you for the honor
of speaking for you where i let you down
forgive me gay god
help me to do better in my next
assignment bless all those who heard
wherever they are on this earth
let the truth long remain in their minds
their god and
draw them to you and produce the image
of christ
bless all the countries where people
tuned in father bless the leaders
now dear god we commit ourselves to you
wrap your arms around us they god draws
to your bosom and keep us there
father keep us there i pray when you
come into your kingdom
save us every member of our families
and those who have come to know you who
have come to know you through our
experience and our example
i pray this sincerely to god
in jesus name let god's people say
amen and amen god bless you all
if ever i come across your mind wherever
you are i'd be very grateful if you will
say father
put your words in that man's mouth god
bless you
[Music]
disappear
here master ultim
master eka master collins
as the fred and we are so blessed
tonight to have our african coordinator
the african ministries who also is the
vice president
of minnesota conference
come forward we're going to pray for you
because i pray for you for your next
assignment for god to be with you
and as a
vice president of minnesota conference
comes
i want to let you know that
[Music]
in this district we have a team
of five pastors that we work very
closely
and we thank god for the ministry has
given to us
may god bless you in your ministry and
wherever you go
they call upon our conference vice
president
pastor brian mugandy who is also the
african ministries coordinator
to say a word and then we'll kneel down
and we pray for pastor randy pasta
and it's your time
but even in church we
want to thank you for attending
these meetings uh there are some of you
there are some of you who were in church
constantly and there are many of you who
watched through uh the platforms that
were provided
we thank you for participating
we thank elder skate for
his ministry here and leading
uh in every night's presentation
going through the word of god
challenging us
to hear the lord's voice
we thank those of you who have accepted
the challenge to live
right to live with god and to join his
remnant church
i'm told that you had baptism this
afternoon we pray that
the churches the churches involved will
support
those new members to allow them to grow
in the faith hold them by the hand and
walk with them
remember they are beginning
you are almost at the end of your
journey so don't expect them to be
like you challenge them to look at you
but support them as they struggle in
their
growth just like you do for your little
ones
we thank elder screed for your ministry
we pray that you will continue to hold
the
fire of the gospel and in your next
assignment
please carry our greetings and our
prayers
as you do god's ministry blessings to
all of you
[Music]
our eternal father
here is your man's servant
kneeling humbly before you
asking to be cleansed and rededicated
for the next
ministry oh lord we pray
that you will fill him with your holy
spirit
that again you will you will touch him
with that call from heaven
that your word may burn in him like fire
so that he will be ready for the next
assignment
we pray for his health we pray for his
strength we pray and we pray lord
that you will sharpen his mind
we pray for the next assignment that
you will open doors for ministry
and lord keep the fire burning
until that time when you will call
all those that have been faithful
to come home we don't forget
those that have committed their lives
today
please keep them faithful and keep the
names written in the book of life
we thank you for hearing and for
answering
our prayer because we have prayed in the
powerful name of jesus
our lord and savior amen
amen amen
[Music]
thank you very much can we go offline
then i said thank you